two of off-broadway's biggest hits two
of their biggest hits musical the
musical and a musical about Star Wars
are now performing at the V theater
Inside Planet Hollywood here to tell us
more is Tom dangora who is the producer
director and co-creator we also have
Kristen Alderson who is a co-star of
musical and Taylor Cruiser who is a
co-star in both shows yes a musical
about Star Wars oh my gosh you guys are
amazing Okay who wants to tackle the
topic of tell me about the two musicals
what are they about okay musical the
musical is one of the longest musicals
in New York history longest running
musicals in New York history it is
basically the short term is it's like
SNL the musical okay all current events
we hit both sides of the aisle and you
will literally laugh hysterically for 70
minutes musical about Star Wars is just
that it's a musical about Star Wars it's
about these two Mega Star Wars fans who
uh wrote the greatest Star Wars musical
of all time and they dream of debuting
it at Comic-Con however they've been
barred from every Comic-Con in America
except one Las Vegas Comic-Con the most
coveted Comic Con of them all I love
this so we you guys brought some props
from the show that you guys use yeah
we'll make these props these are very
nice products so one of the co-writers
and original stars of the show Scott
Foster made the Falcon and our prop
Master Brendan McCann made the R2 out of
paper mache and other things and the
important thing the aesthetic of the
show is that these guys made all the
they made all the props they made all
the costumes we have a whole section of
the show where a sound effect goes off
and we yell cosplay and we run off stage
we change our costumes and we're wearing
a whole brand new Star Wars there are
like 20 changes yeah it's very important
do you have to be a fan of Star Wars to
come in and appreciate the show
don't turn on her but she
I've never seen a Star Wars movie and
when I first saw this show he was not my
boyfriend yet but I saw it and I thought
it was the funniest thing I've ever seen
so I was not biased I was already her
favorite day yes
um I think that it's it's so much fun
it's a great time and it's a laugh
whether you know the inside jokes or not
like you are dying laughing because
there's another side of it there's uh
the character of Emily she has nefarious
intentions she's actually there to bring
Star Wars to its knees and the fight
between the dark side and the good side
right yeah is basically between these
boys and Emily now I want to touch on
musical real quick because a lot of
impressions in the show and Taylor
you're kind of a master of Impressions
what are some of the Impressions that we
see in the show well you imagine Matthew
McConaughey you know you never know when
he's going to show up on television
sound as whiskey or maybe he had on
award show or something like that I
don't know uh and then also we did Trump
we did Trump something
a little bit we did a little bit of
trump I don't know and we gotta we got
Joe Biden in the show too and uh folks
uh wonderful to be here at a channel on
channel one not in channel one not
channel one channel channel two come on
I'm old Sticks and Stones can break my
bones with words I don't remember them I
remember them this is something you guys
thank you so much for joining us real
quick a website to get tickets yes um
you can go to musicallymusical.com or
musical about starwars.com I believe
it's and I think it's
vtheater.com and please come see Emmy
award-winning Kristin Alderson your
favorite soap star for 15 years I want
that to live and all my children in a
general hospital
yes it's a good ladies we love it you
guys thank you so much